>> My name is Mark Spelman.
I'm the Global Head of Strategy at Accenture.
And one of the big debates here having here
in Davos is this whole
question of where are we going with energy
-- particularly, this issue
of the mix between looking at oil and renewables.
And when you talk about energy, you have to
really sort of think about
what's happening on the demand side and what's
happening on the supply
side.
On the demand side, the downturn has meant
that demand for oil is
actually fallen by about three percent although
the underlying
assumption that oil would continue to rise.
But the thing that everybody needs to remember
about energy demand is
that when you look at the forecast, particularly
going out to sort of
2030, the demand for energy is just going
to increase massively,
particularly because of the increases in middle
passes in countries
like India and China.
And what that means is that they want energy
for obviously domestic
living but they also need it for transport.
So the demand for energy is not going to go
away.
The big thing on the supply side is how do
we find the right balance
between particularly oil and gas, nuclear,
renewables, and the key
question that we've got is the speed at which
we can ramp up
renewables.
And the key thing about renewables is that
what you actually, is a
flexible, if you like, energy Internet smart
grid systems, to be able
to bring those renewables on stream to to
sort of give customers more
flexibility.
So as we look at the energy debate, I don't
think it's all about oil
and gas or renewables.
It's about ends.
We need to look at how we optimize energy
efficiency.
We need to manage oil and gas carefully.
Clearly, nuclear is going to be part of the
mix.
But critically, we need to ramp up renewables,
we need more investment
in solar, winds, clean coal.
Sequestration will be critical.
But ultimately we also need smart grids in
order to be able to
facilitate the introduction of those new renewables
at scale, into both
the domestic and residential areas, but also
to help, I think, with
just facilitating more effective use of energy
and matching supply and
demands.
Thanks very much.